Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Ich habe gehört, es sollen Lockerungen kommen. Bist du? Bist du schon locker?
Ich bin locker, ich bin so locker. Ich rege mich schon noch nicht mal mehr über Jens Spahn auf, so locker bin ich.
Logbuchnetzpolitik Nummer dreihundertvierundachtzig, vom dritten März zwanzigeinundzwanzig denkt sich da der,
Hinterhörer und die geübte Hörerin und fragt sich, habt ihr nicht gestern schon eine Sendung aufgenommen?
Haben wir ganz fleißig äh berichtet vom IT-Sicherheitsgesetz und äh was man alles so über Lego und Datenautobahn wissen muss. Aber da war ja noch gar nicht alles drin.
Genau, der war noch gar nicht alles drin und außerdem muss ich auch was loswerden. Ich bin.
Ich habe jetzt lange überlegt, ob ich mich da überhaupt so äußere, ja? Und ich habe eigentlich gedacht, so Comedy-Nuss, du musst auch mal einfach drüberstehen, so, ne? Aber.
Ich muss, ich kann, ich muss mein Schweigen brechen. Ich kann das so nicht stehen lassen. Und ich muss einfach sagen, wie Kacke.
War eigentlich diese Auflösung von Dove Punk.
Bin komplett davor.
Was?
Was soll diese Scheiße bitte?
Album zwanzig dreizehn,
dann machen die ein Auflösungsvideo und sagen, ja übrigens, den einen Roboter, den haben wir in der Wüste in die Luft gejagt und und spielen dann nochmal alte Musik zu. Die haben sich noch nicht mal die Mühe gemacht, ihr Fuck Video da anders zu vertonen
und dann schreiben sie noch dran, sie hätten bis zwanzigeinundzwanzig existiert. Das ist also Frechheit. Ich bin richtig sauer,
Ich bin wirklich enttäuscht. Da kann man sich doch mal ein bisschen Mühe geben, da kann man doch jemanden sagen, produziere doch mal wenigstens noch ein Lied oder sowas, ne. Ich meine, also das, das war wirklich,
Unverschämt. Unverschämt. Weil ich höre den ganzen Tag rauf und runter. Ich liebe die, ne, aber das war wirklich total daneben. So, das kannst du so nicht machen.
Was machen wir denn dann, wenn wir uns mal trennen?
Wir springen dich in der Füße.
Okay. Oh Gott, wie nennt man das, eine Psychologie, wenn die Leute Angst vor der Konsequenz von Trennung haben?
Okay, Thomas, wann haben wir dich eigentlich letztes Mal gehört? Wir haben ja heute noch Thomas dabei.
Stimmt, hallo Thomas.
Mein Gott, ich bin ich bin voll traurig, also Linus hat recht. Äh ich höre die ganze Woche nur noch, darf und bin melancholisch. Ähm äh ja, das letzte Mal war ich im November dabei in der Woche von der Trump-Wahl.
Wieso bist du melancholisch? Was willst du denn hinterher trauern? Die haben doch eh seit zwanzig, dreizehn nix mehr released oder warst du, hast du die irgendwie seit warst du aufm Konzert? Was weiß ich, seit zwanzig, vierzehn oder zwanzig fünfzehn.
Ach nee, aber irgendwie das war für mich immer so der Soundtrack zu den CTC-Veranstaltungen, vor allem für die das letzte Camp, das war für mich sehr,
und ja äh weiß nicht, das waren halt irgendwie so ein paar Grüppchen, wo ich war und da hat das nochmal richtig gut dazu gepasst. Und ich ich werde diese Musik weiter hören und hoffen, dass es irgendwie weitergeht. Prinzip Hoffnung, keine Ahnung. Ähm
es war traurig, ja.
Ich find's halt, also weißt du, du kannst dich, du kannst dich auflösen mit einem Abschlussalbum, das hätte man mit radom Access Memorys auch machen können, ne. Übrigens, der letzte äh Song auf Random Excess Memorys, der klingt ja auch schon ein bisschen so wie so eine Auflösung.
Ja? So ein irgendwie Bruch und so und Ende und super geiler Song. Ähm aber du kannst halt nicht,
also so nicht. Du kannst nicht irgendwie sagen, ach übrigens, den einigen von euch ist vielleicht schon aufgefallen, dass wir mal wieder acht Jahre nix äh produziert haben und äh,
Nee, so macht man das nicht. So macht man das nicht. Ein Song noch irgendetwas, ja.
Von mir aus oder was auch immer, ne? Könnte man sich ja irgendwie was überlegen, aber so kann man das nicht machen. Das äh.
Immer dieser Anspruchshaltung von Fans, wie willst du dich denn überhaupt in die Rolle von so Weltstars äh einfühlen?
Die können sich vollkommen frei bewegen.
Sie sind ja keine, klar, es sind absolute Weltstars, es stimmt, aber äh ich glaube, die letzten überlieferten Fotos oder Videos von denen sind irgendwie zwanzig, dreißig Jahre alt oder so, ne?
Das stimmt.
Und äh da äh nee, aber nein, so macht man das nicht,
Vor allem du kannst die können mir jetzt auch nicht erzählen, sie hätten mangelndes Gefühl, weil die können ja gefühlt in ihren Liedern ausdrücken. Weißt du, wenn Kraftwerke sich so aufgelöst hätte oder auflösen würde, ne, würde ich sagen, ja okay. Aber ähm,
doch nicht jemand, doch nicht die. Nee, das geht so nicht. Nein, das ist einfach stillos. So, sorry.
Herbe Enttäuschung. Können sie sich auflösen? Ist ja nur, haben genug gute Musik gemacht. Es ist völlig okay, ja. Aber und ich finde es auch nicht tragisch, dass sie sich auflösen, weil gibt ja genug gute Musik und die ist ja jetzt nicht weg, ne. Aber äh so kannst du das nicht machen
Das ist einfach, so geht's eigentlich.
Genau, was erlaube darf.
Also du kannst dir, du kannst halt nicht so äh das ist ja geplant. Also warum gehen die hin und sagen hier ähm der Roboter wird in die Luft gesprengt. Das geht so nicht.
Nee, aber sie haben sogar eben noch dieses Epilogvideo rausgegeben, aber die Pressesprecherin hat dann keinen Grund für die Auflösung gegeben.
Ist ja erkennbar in dem Video. Der eine ist jetzt halt in Luft gesprengt worden. Als ich meinen Tag geht nicht, ey.
Nee, ich glaube, da kommt noch was. Das, das, das war noch nicht das Letzte.
Ach, immer dieses Leben in der Vergangenheit. Ich beschäftige mich mehr mit der Zukunft.
Die sieht ja besonders gut aus, Tim. Da haben wir ja.
Also musikalisch ist da, glaube ich, eine Menge zu holen.
Thema, die musikalische Zukunft.
Ja. Es interessiert mich mehr.
Nee, also,
Das geht so, nein, also äh okay, du hast, du hast Recht. Es könnte halt sein, dass du jetzt irgendwie irgendeine total reale Nummer machen und das ist jetzt irgendwie alle paar Wochen ein neues Video gibt und äh sich da irgendwie was dann darf neu erfinden oder sowas, ne?
Das wäre die einzige Entschuldigung.
Das ist doch auch nicht das letzte Wort, ich bitte dich. Sogar KLF ist ja sogar zurückgekommen.
Ich ich frage mich nur grade in der letzten Sendung, wo ich war, hatten wir das beste Ort.
Diese Zukunft, von der du immer redest, Tim?
Von siebenundachtzig bis zweiundneunzig von dreiundneunzig bis fünfundneunzig und von und neunzehnhundertsiebenundneunzig und seit zweitausendsiebzehn. Okay, das sind professionelle Zurückkomma.
Ja und die wissen das auch so inszenieren,
Ich meine da äh Roboter in der Wüste sprengt. Die haben erstmal ihr Geld verbrannt. Das war so ihr Auftakt. Und danach wurd's eigentlich immer verrückter. Aber das sind ja auch echte.
Oje. Ich wusste, dass du mir das Thema wegnimmst, um zu deinen diskordinanischen äh Religiösen dazu kommen.
Religiönchen.
Ich will mich jetzt aufregen über dieses Video von Dove Punk.
Ja, hast du ja auch.
Ja, aber ich möchte jetzt weiter mich darüber aufregen.
Okay, gut, dann müssen wir aber noch schnell den Podcast umbenennen.
Okay, wir müssen da kurz einen Podcast machen. Ähm müssen noch ein bisschen was nach äh fügen zu.
Zu zu Telekommunikationsmodernisierungsgesetz. Ich hab ja wie gesagt schon gesagt, dass ich, wie gesagt, hab ich das ja gesagt gehabt, ne? Hab ich gesagt gehabt. Das.
Das Frankteil an dem TK Mock war und nur zu einem Teil davon. Und dieses TK Mock ist ja irgendwie so ein vierhundert Seitenmonster.
Und er war eben quasi zu dem Breitbandausbau geladen. Das war ja eine vierstündige Anhörung dort, äh zu der er sich dann irgendwie nur für zwei Stunden hat, zuschalten lassen, weil die da so viel zu besprechen hatten und so viel zu zuhören hatten. Und,
Ja, stellt sich raus. Die haben offenbar den CCC halt nicht zu den Sachen gefragt, wo äh sagen wir mal, die Musik wirklich spielt.
Und deswegen habe ich mir jetzt mal noch so ein bisschen angeschaut ähm was äh pernene äh von Mailbox dot org, Mailbox dot Orchessen ähm E-Mail-Anbieter ähm,
da kommentiert hat, weil nämlich mit dem sich dann doch noch einiges für,
E-Mail-Anbieter und sonstige geändert hat und auch das aktuelle Aufregerthema in Sachen Horst Seehofer spielt da eine Rolle. Aber als allererstes muss Thomas uns mal erklären,
Warum haben wir überhaupt einen TK-Mock.
Ja, also ähm das Tickermock äh nicht heißt in in anderen Ländern auch TKG oder Telekommunikations,
und äh diese Debatte schlägt gerade in allen Ländern der EU auf, weil es an äh einen neuen Rechtsrahmen gibt, den sogenannten European Electronic Communication Codes oder.
C, ähm dieses Gesetz wurde zwanzig achtzehn beschlossen und ersetzt den alten EU-Rechtsrahmen aus zweitausendneun, so jede Dekade reformiert man irgendwie die Rahmenbedingungen für
Telekommunikationsnetze in der EU und ähm ja, diese Reform ähm wurde eben so zwanzig achtzehn abgeschlossen auf EU-Ebene und weißen Richtlinie ist, muss es in jedem Land nachgezogen werden und in nationales Recht überführt
Ähm die Deadline dafür war im Dezember zwanzig zwanzig. Und äh ich glaube im Jänner war es oder Februar, dass die EU-Kommission,
eine Mahnung rausgeschickt hat an vierundzwanzig der siebenundzwanzig EU Mitgliedsstaaten. Ähm das sprich, es hat niemand recht.
Mal, wer keine bekommen hat.
Äh keiner bekommen, hat äh Finnland, Griechenland und Ungarn. Ähm.
Das sind die Streber, keine Ahnung, wieso gerade die Länder, also Finnland ist Vorbild bei Telekommunikation, die haben ja auch irgendwie gar keine Volumenbegrenzungen mehr. Bei den anderen beiden habe ich,
keine Ahnung, wieso die so schnell fertig waren,
Aber wie gesagt, die anderen vierundzwanzig müssen nachsitzen und ähm das ist so der erste Schritt, den die Kommission hat, ein Vertragsverletzungsverfahren einzuleiten. Das ist jetzt mal nur ein Schuss auf dem Bug und die meisten Länder wollen das gerade machen und
man rädert sich natürlich auch auf Corona aus. Was,
nicht ganz von der Hand zu weisen ist. Äh und deswegen ähm gibt's in Deutschland diese Debatte und auch in Österreich, wozu wir später noch kommen.
Ja, okay. Und bei der Gelegenheit regelt man sich irgendwie seine komplette.
Telekommunikation eben neu, wir haben ja in der letzten Sendung gestern da schon ein bisschen drüber gesprochen, über den Teil, den der CCC Sachverständigen durfte.
Und gestern Abend liegte dann quasi während unserer Sendung der E-Mail-Anbeter Posteo ein ähm ja, ein Wunschkonzert des.
BMI und zwar ein Dokument unter dem TKG-Novelle Themen für das Parlamentarische Verfahren,
Ja, und dann irgendwie Regelungsort, Forderung, ja? Und irgendwie so die Innenministerkonferenz. Also da kommen jetzt so die Innenminister und sagen, was übrigens noch so ein bisschen in das Gesetz rein könnte.
Die Frage ist, warum also das Gesetz kommt ja schon quasi von der Regierung, ja? Wieso gießt das,
BMI da jetzt nochmal in das parlamentarische Verfahren nachforderungen ein. Also sie würden gerne.
TK Dienste zur Mitwirkung bei der Quellen-TKÜ verpflichten. Sie würde.
Nummern, unabhängige TK-Dienste gerne zur Speicherung von Identifizierungsmerkmalen verpflichten? Also, das bedeutet, ne.
Dass eben Dienste, die nicht an die Telefonnummer gebunden sind, nehmen wir mal Threema,
sie trotzdem Identifikationsmerkmale speichern müssen um im Zweifelsfall die Anschlussinhaberin rausrücken zu können. TK Dienste sollen zu einer
unverzüglichen, vollständigen Übermittlung von Bestandsdaten verpflichtet werden, klar, genau das wieder, ne? Ähm
dann würden sie nochmal ein bisschen nachregeln die Pflichten der Telekommunikationsdiensteanbieter würden den Begriff der Bestandsdaten anpassen, den Begriff der Verkehrsdaten anpassen. Bei Auskunftsersuchen
die Leute verpflichten dafür Daten zu erheben,
eine zusammenhängende und vollständige Überwachungskopie soll angefertigt werden, na? Also es ist dann so dieses hier wenn wir.
Überwachung haben wollen, dann wollen wir da auch sehen, eine unverschlüsselte Ausleitung in Romingfällen wollen sie haben,
die unentdeckte Nutzung von sicherstellen genauen Standortdaten erheben, die Erreichbarkeit von TK-Diensten verbessern,
Also da meinen sie natürlich nicht, dass wir besseres Internet kriegen, sondern dass die jederzeit drangehen müssen, wenn Polizei oder BMI was von denen will, ne? Äh TK Dienste zur Erteilung von Auskünften, unter anderem zu Netzstrukturen verpflichten,
TK Dienste zu besonderen Absicherungen bei der Speicherung von Anordnungsdaten im Zusammenhang mit TKÜ-Maßnahmen verpflichten. Ähm,
und die Meldepflicht ans BKA bei Daten League fällen. So, das sind irgendwie so Wunschliste fünfzehn Punkte.
Und natürlich diese Rufnummern, unabhängige TK-Dienste zur Speicherung von Identifizierungsmerkmalen verpflichten. Das wäre dann eben, ja, am Ende Personalausweispflicht für,
E-Mail und äh Messenger, ne. Entsprechend groß war natürlich auch die Resonanz da drauf. Man muss aber eben betonen,
Das ist nicht etwas, was in dem Gesetz steht. Das ist ein Blatt Papier. Ohne Logo, ohne Briefkopf,
gar nichts. Einfach nur ein, also kein offizielles Dokument, sondern im Zweifelsfall einfach etwas, was die quasi so,
noch mit dazugegeben haben und gesagt haben, hör mal, hier in der wenn's geht, liebe CDU Hardliner, vielleicht könnte er das ja noch mit reinprügeln im parlamentarischen Verfahren.
Und das wurde jetzt, glaube ich, in den letzten vierundzwanzig Stunden ein bisschen stärker gekocht, als es ist. Deswegen macht es durchaus mal Sinn, bisschen darauf zu schauen, okay, was steht denn drin?
Kannst du nochmal kurz sagen, von wem kam das jetzt genau?
BMI. Der Bundesministerium fürs Innere Heimat und Bau und äh und ähm Modelleisenbahn.
An die, an die CDU-Fraktion oder an.
Steht nicht, es wurde mehr oder weniger geliebt. Es ist ein Papier aus gut informierten Kreisen ähm.
Die Identifizierungspflicht ist weiterhin vom Tisch. Äh frühere Version des Papier hatte sogar eine Entschlüsselungspflicht für Anbieter enthalten, die es aber nun raus. Es ist im Prinzip sowas so.
Na ja, also ein Forderungspapier aus dem Innenministerium.
Steht aber nix drauf, da steht drauf Seite eins von achtundzwanzig und ähm so Formulierungsvorschläge. Also wie gesagt, der Eindruck ist.
Die Vermutung, die Hypothese ist, ne, weil das BMI kann ja mit reindefinieren in.
Die TKG-Novelle und NST Hamburg. So, die Vermutung ist, dass sie in der Koalition irgendwie diese Forderung nicht durchgekriegt haben und sie deswegen versuchen, naja okay, gießen wir es nochmal ins Parlament. Mal gucken, ob da vielleicht noch irgendjemand.
Mit reindrücken möchte.
Reagiert. Okay.
Und insofern ist es halt ein bisschen also es zeugt auf jeden Fall einfach mal davon, dass ja also kaum jemand.
So so eine starke Verachtung für für die Grundrechte und die Verfassung der Bundesrepublik Deutschland, wie ausgerechnet zu Horst Seehofer. Es äh zeigt außerdem.
Natürlich eben den Teil, den sie nicht reingekriegt haben und genau deswegen macht's halt auch mehr Sinn, so die These.
Mal zu schauen, was sie denn reingekriegt haben. Und da würde ich eben jetzt mal schauen, quasi in der TK Mock Anhörung, die ja da stattgefunden hat am Montag. Und da wurde eben eine,
Stellungnahme unter anderem eingereicht von und der beschwert sich quasi, ne? Also der beschwert sich ja quasi über die.
Den Teil, der in dem Gesetz drin steht.
Der kritisiert, ähm na also aus technischer Sicht, aus wirtschaftlicher Sicht und aus politischer Sicht so ein bisschen die Maßnahmen. Ähm gesellschaftlich,
Ne, so, also einfach mal so, was, was habt ihr hier eigentlich vor, ne? Auskunftsverfahren und TKÜ, sagt er dann zum Beispiel auch, ich meine, wo sind denn da die Grenzen,
und ähm na ja, was ja jetzt zum Beispiel drin steht, ist.
Paragraph hundertneunundsechzig folgende verpflichtet die werden die Telekommunikationsanbieter verpflichtet zur Vorhaltung einer durch die technische Richtlinie,
äh TKIV, der Bundesnetzagentur präventiv installierten Überwachungsschnittstelle
Also die müssen jetzt eine zertifizierte Überwachungsschnittstelle einbauen und die muss vorgehalten werden, unabhängig davon, ob da jetzt nachher einer nachfragt oder nicht. Aber die sind natürlich mit Kosten verbunden.
Ähm es wird außerdem eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung quasi eingeführt. Ja, dazu, ich zitiere jetzt mal aus der Stellungnahme.
Paragraph hundertfünfundsiebzig TK Mod G E in mehreren Fällen,
und über Jahre hinweg ist die Einführung einer, also das ist jetzt aus der Stellungnahme, ne? Eine anlasslose Fortseitenspeicherung vom Bundesverfassungsgericht als Verfassungswidrig beziehungsweise vom EuGH als Unionsrechtswidrig, erkannt worden, der aktuelle Gesetzesentwurf,
nicht erkennen,
Bedenken dieser hohen Gerichte auch nur ansatzweise Rechnung getragen wurde, so finden sich keinerlei Einschränkungen der Verwertungsmöglichkeiten, beispielsweise eine Limitierung auf schwere Straftaten. Gleichzeitig werden,
von einer VDS Quaddefinition fast ausnahmslos unbeteiligte Nutzer präventiv erfasst. Es ist nach wie vor nicht davon auszugehen, dass die Regelung des Gesetzentwurfs,
Bundesverfassungsgerichts oder EuGH Bestand haben.
Vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht und dem EuGH Bestand haben. Schon jetzt sind gegen die bisherigen Regelungen von der zeitigen ähm.
Von der derzeitigen und immer wieder für rechtswidrig erkannten und derzeit ausgesetzten Vorratsdatenspeicherung weitere laufende Verfassungsbeschwerden vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht anhängig. Wir selbst sind dort Beschwerdeführer. Naja und dann kommt eben.
Vorratsdatenspeicherung und Kommunikationssicherheitsstellungspflicht. Ähm also die sollen quasi als kritische Infrastruktur.
Ja besondere Anforderungen erfüllen, dass sie dass sie immer funktionieren, ne? Insgesamt geht's also hier um,
Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
und äh TKÜ, die dadrin geregelt sind und jetzt ist das spannende, ne, das ist ja eigentlich ein Telekommunikationsmodernisierungsgesetz, aber durch diese in diesem Telekommunikationsmodernisierungsgesetz wird eine ganze Reihe von.
Telemediendiensten in diese ebene Telekommunikation gehoben. Du bist nämlich als E-Mail-Anbieter kein,
Telekommunikationsanbieter. Du bist als Messenger-Anbieter kein Telekommunikationsanbieter, das bist du, wenn du ein Telekommunikationsnetz, Mobilfunknetz oder ein Telefonnetz unterhältst,
und das ist die Lücke, die die Lücke in Anführungszeichen, die sie schließen wollen. Das hat natürlich auch gewisse Vorteile, ja, aber das hat vor allem einfach mal einen Haufen Nachteile, wenn es um diesen ganzen.
Äh Überwachungskrempel geht. Und das ist, glaube ich, der Teil, auf dem man sich hier ähm gerade eher konzentrieren muss.
Wobei natürlich trotzdem ist dabei bleibt das äh es eben einfach sehr bedenklich ist.
Wie, ne, dieses Gesetz hat, glaube ich, vier, fünfhundert Seiten, ne? Und das ist irgendwie, das wird ja jetzt mit einer vier Stunden Anhörung durchs durch den Bundestag geprügelt. Und wer weiß, was man da noch nicht gesehen hat, weil das teilweise eben querbezüge zu anderen Gesetzen hat,
in den definiert ist, wer davon betroffen ist. Und jetzt wird quasi das andere Gesetz zeitgleich oder kurz darauf geändert und plötzlich gelten die Regeln aus dem TK Mott Mock,
einmal noch für andere Leute und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich blick da auch noch nicht ganz durch.
Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube auch nicht, dass das äh Papier jetzt hier.
An Face Value bewertet werden sollte, also dass dieser, dies, dass die sich wirklich jetzt entscheiden, mit diesen Forderungen um die Ecke zu kommen von diesen fünfzehn Punkten,
ist nichts neu. Das sind fünfzehn Forderungen, wie du sie irgendwie auch schon vor fünf oder sechs Jahren hättest hören können von äh den Innenministerien dieser Welt.
Und äh ich meine, die die Richtlinie ist vom Dezember zwanzig achtzehn. Das heißt, man hat ja jetzt über zwei Jahre Zeit,
einzubauen in der Regierung, aber man ist ja sogar schon säumig, dass man sozusagen jetzt, wo die Zeit schon drängt, wo die öffentliche Debatte und der parlamentarische Prozess eh schon in einer Pandemie besonders hastig
durchgeboxt werden muss, mit so einer langen Liste von Forderungen zu kommen. Also ich ich glaube, dass der die.
Beeinflussung der Diskussion fast genauso wichtig ist wie irgendeiner einzelne dieser Forderungen in diesem Papier.
Wie sieht's denn bei euch in Österreich aus? Wird bei euch auch neue äh Überwachungen eingeführt durch die TKG-Novelle?
Nein, also wir haben keinen neuen Überwachungsmethoden. Es wird etwas äh gelöscht, was Betroffene darüber informiert, wenn sie von einer Überwachung betroffen waren. Also wenn,
meine Daten durch eine Funkzellenabfrage herausgegeben wurden oder ähm meine IP-Adresse irgendwo auftauchte und dann holen sie sich meine Stammdaten dazu. Würde ich bisher davon in Kenntnis gesetzt werden? Das passiert in der Praxis leider
auch nicht so, wie man sich's wünschen würde, aber eigentlich gibt's die Verpflichtung und diese Verpflichtung wollen sie löschen. Und das ist auch was, wo wir uns in unserer Stellungnahme,
aufgeregt haben und auch einen Gegenvorschlag gemacht haben, wie man diese Informationspflichten so lösen könnte, dass sie auch in der Praxis ankommen.
War übrigens auch eine Änderung, die vom Innenministerium reinkam, aber da eben schon in dem Begutachtungsentwurf, also ähm bei dem öffentlichen Papier, was für alle gleichzeitig dann auflag und nicht im Nachhinein dann irgendwie, wenn das Ding schon so halblich Parlament ist.
In welchem Stand ist das jetzt da so insgesamt bei euch gerade? Also ähnlich wie bei uns.
Wir hatten ja, ich meine, ich weiß nicht, was ihr in in der letzten Sendung so besprochen habt, es gibt natürlich klassische Telekom-Themen auch, die da drinnen sind.
Thomas Hess, du weißt nicht, was wir in der letzten Sendung besprochen haben.
Die war doch erst gestern, die habe ich noch nicht gehört. Ähm ist vor einer Stunde hier äh veröffentlicht worden.
Es ist tatsächlich richtig, also die die wurde wirklich erst kurz vor vor unserem Aufzeichnungsbeginn veröffentlicht. Also das wäre wenn du jetzt gesagt hättest, du hättest sie schon gehört, hätte ich dir nicht geglaubt. Wer zeitlich nicht hingekommen ist, ist entschuldigt dieses eine Mal aber auch nur.
Danke, das erleichtert mich. Ähm.
Sonst treibe ich dich in die Wüste und springe nicht da.
Ja, also, aber weil ich das nicht weiß, ist im Kern äh,
Das Deutsche es hat ist das Problem ist bekannt. Schlechtes Internet in Deutschland, darüber müssen wir hier gar nicht mehr sprechen. Und ähm mich hat nur gewundert, auch in der Anhörung im Bundestag, über die ich nur Berichterstattung gelesen habe,
dann so Leute wie Thomas Fetzer irgendwie meinen, dafür müssen wir Steuergeld verwenden und auf keinen Fall die Telekom Konzerne dazu verpflichten, die Leitungen zu modernisieren.
Wer Thomas Fetzer nicht kennt, dass es ein Jurist aus Deutschland, der für die Deutsche Telekom gerne Rechtsgutachten schreibt
Ähm die ja hat sich bei Stream On auch verdient gemacht, indem er so Argumente gebracht hat. Man kann irgendwie
diskriminieren, wie man will, solange es in den AGBs steht, das war seine Rechtsmeinung, die musste bis zum EuGH gehen, der hat dann gesagt, nein das stimmt natürlich nicht
Also das sind so die Meinungen in in Deutschland, äh die halt einfach das Internet nicht besser machen und in Österreich ist es die andere Richtung. Wir haben ja eigentlich
äh ganz gutes, billiges Netz mit viel Datenvolumen um wenig Euro und das wird jetzt schlechter.
Und da verteilt sie gerade die Weichen dafür, ähm dass es eben äh die Regulierungsbehörde äh politisiert wird und entmachtet wird.
Wir haben in Österreich sehr viel virtuelle Mobilfunkanbieter, die die Preise drücken und für Wettbewerb sorgen, deren,
Grundlage läuft jetzt dann bald aus, also die haben bisher die Netze,
leichter verwenden können. Künftig müssen sie äh Deals machen mit den Mobilfunkern. Und das wird
ziemlich äh negative Konsequenzen haben. Und insofern ist es besonders besorgniserregend, wenn mit dem TKG in Österreich auch die
ähm Konsumentenschutz äh Rechte eingeschränkt werden, also so eines der großen Probleme ist ja,
dass man ewig lange in diesen Verträgen eingesperrt ist. Ich hab in Österreich einen Vertrag, den ich gar nicht wegsurfen und telefonieren kann und die kann ich jedes Monat kündigen. Und jetzt gehen sie aber in die Richtung, dass sie von den zwölf
Monaten, maximale Mindestvertragsdauer auf vierundzwanzig Monate hochgehen?
Wenn du ein Telefon dazu bekommen hast zu deinem Vertrag und dann kündigst du vorzeitig weil die AGBs sich ändern,
musst du zukünftig was zahlen für das Gerät, überhaupt dieses Recht zu kündigen, wenn die AGBs sich ändern, nicht ausschließlich zu dem Vorteil, ähm der Kundin, dann hast du auch keine Möglichkeit mehr, aus dem Vertrag rauszukommen.
Also es sind so lauter Stellschrauben, an denen sie drehen, die am Ende, die in dem Markt schlechter machen werden und ähm deswegen ist es
umso schlimmer, dass das grade in so einer Zeit kommt, wo ähm wir jetzt grade wirklich gemerkt haben, wie abhängig die Gesellschaft von von Internetleistungen ist, das haben wir ja seit der Pandemie die ganze Zeit schon gepredigt und ich glaube, ich habe es auch ein paar Mal in der Sendung gesagt,
Wir brauchen irgendwie äh ähm vor allem für Haushalte, die kein Festnetzanschluss haben, dringend eine Lösung, weil du kannst nicht äh Home Schooling und Homeoffice machen,
äh fünf Gigabyte im Monat. Das geht einfach nicht. Und das wäre auch die Chance gewesen für diese Gruppenangebote zu schaffen, das hat man,
vergessen oder ignoriert, ähm bei der bei der Netzzentralität gab es auch nochmal äh Änderungen, die sogar in die positive Richtung gehen. Also die Strafen werden erhöht,
wenn man gegen die Netzzentralität verstößt in Österreich. Das sind jetzt äh nicht mehr achtundfünfzig, sondern hunderttausend Euro. Was, was ganz gut ist.
Ja und Telefonzellen werden abgeschafft, aber das ist, glaube ich, das wenigste, was äh die Digitalisierung betrifft.
Hm. Und bei euch auch nicht. Also durchwachsen.
Telefonzellen werden abgeschafft.
Die werden aus der Verpflichtung im Universaldienst rausgestrichen und deswegen ja,
Moment, du verpflichtest da irgendwie Netzbetreiber, Telefonzellen aufzustellen und ähm diese Verpflichtung fällt,
Und äh das äh ist halt auch schade, weil es gibt kein Konzept, was man danach machen sollte, weil das ist Infrastruktur, die gibt's überall und man könnte sich ja was überlegen von WLAN-Hotspot,
überweist nicht, äh äh öffentliches äh Coworking oder ein äh öffentliches Bücherregal, Kühlschrank für Foodsharing, whatever, aber,
die Dinger haben Netz, die Dinger haben Strom
der Grund gehört nicht einheitlich dem Bund, also man müsste sich sicherlich lokal was überlegen, aber es ist halt schade, dass man einfach die Verpflichtung wegnimmt und damit werden die sehr wahrscheinlich abgerissen.
Und ähm ich glaube, da gäbe es zukunftsweisendere Nutzungsformen.
Ja
Ich weiß nicht, was wie schaut's mit äh die die Telefonzellen in Österreich, dass äh in Deutschland, das wäre auch nochmal spannend, weil die sind ja überall in Deutschland und ist da irgendwas auch in dem Gesetz drinnen diesbezüglich? Da stelle ich jetzt wahrscheinlich eine blöde Frage.
Es gibt noch Telefonzellen. Also aber ich habe keine ähm ich habe keine ich habe lange keine mehr gesehen, wo man reingehen kann.
Die hatten wir ja vor einigen Jahren, weil da glaube ich mal so ein Luftbild von der, von so einer Sammelstelle außerhalb von Berlin, wo die die alle gestapelt hatten.
Dann haben sie dir auch verkauft, die Telefonzellen.
Die gelben waren aber schneller weg als die Magentafarbenen, die wollte natürlich keiner haben und.
Es gibt aber noch so, ja, so halb also so halboffen, damit da keiner, da kann keiner drin wohnen oder so, ne? Aber ich ich habe tatsächlich gibt's noch so ein Münzfansprecher,
Wenn man, wenn man da mal drauf achtet, sind das auch gar nicht so wenige. Man man erkennt die meistens daran, dass die von irgendjemandem Wander wandalisiert wurden.
Ich meine, was man schon noch irgendwie dazu sagen muss, nachdem in den meisten EU-Ländern inzwischen ja SIM-Karten registriert sein müssen, auf eine Person.
Ähm ist äh die Telefonzelle einer der wenigen Wege noch anonym zu telefonieren, vor allem für technisch nicht so versierte Menschen.
Und ähm wenn ich mit investigativen Journalistinnen rede, höre ich das oft, dass es hat eben so die Wertkarten, Handys waren und jetzt noch die Telefonzellen, wie du einer Quelle, die wirklich in Gefahr ist, weil sie mit dir spricht, äh so ein bissel Tipps geben kannst,
und insofern ist das natürlich auch schade, dass wir hier jetzt nochmal den Überwachungsdruck erhöhen und so ein Weg abschneiden.
Das kommt halt auf der, auf das rechtliche rechtliche Gefüge an, ne. Also klar, natürlich ist es schön, äh anonyme Kommunikations zu haben und die scheinen ja auch nicht übermäßig äh missbraucht zu werden, wenn ich mich umschaue, aber
den Innenminister offenbar anders.
Ja
Es ist halt einfach schade, dass das hier alles Dienst nach Vorschrift ist und nicht wirklich dieses Zukunftsgericht hätte, also man muss ja fast sagen, die einzigen Mitgestaltungswillen sind die Überwachungspolitiker.
Und das finde ich sehr schade.
Aber gut, ähm vielleicht lassen wir das Telekommunikationsrecht und kommen zu einem anderen großen Thema. Ähm ich.
Riesen Thema.
Ja, eines von dem ich gehofft habe, es bleibt uns erspart, ähm und deswegen wollte ich auch irgendwie in die in die Sendung heute, weil.
Ich glaube, das verdient Aufmerksamkeit und ähm.
Es geht um elektronische Immunitätsausweise und ähm darum, wie dieses Thema gerade eskaliert.
Ich glaube,
war die äh LMP dreihunderteinundvierzig von neunzehnten April zwanzig zwanzig, wo dieses äh Thema Corona-Hotel das erste Mal auf.
Linus, da hast du auch schon äh so grob skizziert diese Idee, wenn du's dann überstanden hast die Krankheit, dann bist du ja,
Sehr wahrscheinlich, damals noch inzwischen, glaube ich, können wir das mit mehr Sicherheit sagen, immun, zumindest für eine gewisse Zeit. Und ähm daran geknüpft sind natürlich.
Eine andere Situation. Man könnte es Privilegien nennen. In Wirklichkeit ist es nur du bist dann halt nicht mehr von den Grundrechtseinschränkungen betroffen, die wir langläufig Lockdown nennen.
Es heißt Impfprivilegien in der Debatte, aber dieses Wort ist wirklich ein bissel problematisch.
Kommt drauf an, wie du da drauf legst.
Äh die Impfung ist ein Privileg, aber die die dass du dann irgendwie, weiß nicht, ähm dich wieder mit Leuten treffen kannst und die umarmen darfst. Ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Privileg ist, weil das ist ja eigentlich nur,
normalen Grundrechte, die wir vorher gehabt haben. Wir nennen, wir nennen unsere Grundrechte ja sonst auch nicht Privilegien.
Ist das schon ein Privileg, dass wir welche haben?
Wenn alle ein bestimmtes Recht nicht haben und einige wenige haben das, dann ist es ein Privileg.
Und wenn alle ein bestimmtes Recht haben und einige wenige nicht, dann ist es eine Diskriminierung. Aber sonst ist es doch aber es ist doch in beiden Fällen das Gleiche oder nicht?
Es ist auf jeden Fall eine Besserstellung, eine subjektive, ja.
Es ist halt so, ich ich weiß nicht, wir haben am Anfang der Pandemie gesagt, so dass hier ist Ausnahme und wir müssen schauen, was dies dass das nicht normal wird, was wir hier hinnehmen. Und äh unter dem,
der Überschrift steht für mich diese ganze Diskussionen, die wir da gerade reinkommen. Das wird sagen für geimpfte Menschen gelten andere Regeln, was teilweise sachlich gerechtfertigt ist.
Aber ja, diese Debatte nennen wir es Impfprivilegien damit alle wissen, worum's geht,
Die ist äh jetzt eben eskaliert und da es letzte Woche in Österreich einiges passiert und inzwischen hat's auch die EU-Ebene erreicht. Ähm,
Wir hatten äh kurz mal Backgroß in Österreich ist es so, äh dass wir schon seit einiger Zeit dieses Konzept, das
ähm äh der Eintrittstests haben. Also wenn du zum Friseur gehen willst oder andere körpernahe Dienstleistungen in Anspruch nehmen willst, dann musst du
einen äh Anti-Gentest vorweisen, den du auch nicht selber zu Hause machen kannst, sondern in einer Apotheke oder in einer in einer Teststraße und dann kriegst du so ein Zertifikat,
dass für achtundvierzig Stunden gilt.
Und da dadurch haben sich die Leute in Österreich schon dran gewöhnt, dass man irgendwie wirtschaftliche Tätigkeit und das Öffnen verbindet mit Tests.
Was an sich ja auch glaube ich ein ein verständlicher Zugang ist, weil dadurch sind die Testzahlen in Österreich stark gestiegen und man erlaubt diese Dienstleistungen dann eben wieder in einem,
einigermaßen sichereren Rahmen. Ähm Österreich ist trotzdem dabei, noch weiter zu öffnen,
und wir öffnen jetzt gerade so in die dritte, vierte Welle hinein, obwohl B eins, eins, sieben gerade massiv ansteigt. Äh also die britische Mutation. Österreich ist da gerade an keinem guten Zustand, aber,
Es gibt da politischen Druck zu öffnen.
Und ähm der Ball ins Rollen gekommen ist über eine Einreiseverordnung des Innenministers in Österreich,
die nämlich nur vorgesehen hat, OK, also auf diesen Test, die man bei der Einreise braucht, die müssen entweder 'n ärztliches, ärztliches Attest haben, einen Barcode oder einen QR-Code.
Keinerlei Informationen darüber, was da in diesen Codes drinnen stehen sollte, also da hätte man auch.
Reinschreiben können, äh aber in der Verordnung war halt drinnen so, die müssen einen QR-Code haben. Ähm und äh,
die wurde zwei, drei Wochen vorher äh äh beschlossen, also war der Verordnung, konnte der Minister selber machen und natürlich geraten alle in Panik und man hat dann eben,
sozusagen schnell Systeme ausgerollt, um äh dieses System der Eintrittstests,
ähm auch nochmal eben mit QR Codes zu versehen und den dazugehörigen Softwaresystemen.
Und dann gab es sozusagen im Windschatz.
Warte mal, wo wird der wo wird der jetzt kontrolliert? Also wer kontrolliert den QR-Code jetzt?
Also im Grunde musst du diesen Zettel äh dir bestätigt, dass du dann getestet wurdest und was das Ergebnis war.
Vorzeigen bei einem Friseur. Wenn du zum Friseur gehen willst, dann muss der den Zettel kontrollieren und eigentlich auch deinen Ausweis. Und ähm,
ich hab's jetzt noch nicht durchgespielt, wie es mit dem QR-Codes ist. Ähm wir haben uns die aber angeschaut, die in Wien ausgegeben werden seit dieser Woche, also seit ähm,
ersten März und äh das ist im Grunde nur ein QR-Code auf äh den URL entcodet hat und dann gehst du da drauf und hast die Initialen der Person,
das Geburtsjahr und den genauen Time-Stand, also Zeitpunkt waren die Testung erfolgt ist. Also im Grunde reicht das, um zurückzuführen, was.
Und die Prüfung macht nimmt deine Friseurin jetzt vor mit ihrem mitm Handy oder womit macht die das?
Also bisher war es so.
App oder was?
Die Zettel, die sie bisher ausgeteilt haben,
waren komplett formlos. Das waren A4-Ausdruck ohne Stempel, ohne Unterschrift. Das also leichter fälschen geht gar nicht.
Und die die werden auch nicht kopiert oder so, die zeigst du kurz her und das war's. Und.
Äh jetzt mit dem QR-Code ist es halt eben so, dass du hier schon einen,
eben eine URL hast, sprich du hast dann halt den Zugriff von dem jeweiligen Laden und dazugehörigen IP-Adresse auf diesen zentralisierten Server, wo dieses Zertifikat vorgehalten.
Das ist das System in Wien wohlgemerkt. Das gibt es sonst nicht, aber das ist das einzige, was wir uns jetzt,
Mittwoch am, seit Montag gibt's das. So schnell anschauen konnten.
Und äh der Bund entwickelt aber ein ähnliches Testsystem. Auch dort sind schon Q A kurz drauf. Die sind aber in den anderen Bundesländern aktiv, da äh sind wir dankbar für Datenspenden, aber die werden sehr ähnlich sein. Das ist eine URL und dort findest du das Testzertifikat.
Und ähm nun endet die Geschichte aber nicht hier.
Letzte Woche wurde im Nationalrat wurden Gesetze beschlossen und sowas hab ich wirklich noch nie erlebt,
am am vierzehnten Februar, also vor zwei Wochen gab es so eine Initiativantrag von paar Abgeordneten, der war eigentlich nur dafür da, um äh drei Rechtschreibfehler in zwei Gesetzen zu korrigieren.
Epidemie-Gesetz und Gesundheitsselematikgesetz. An der, der, der geht dann sozusagen.
Gelegenheit haben sie mal noch.
Exakt. Sie haben, sie haben das gestartet, ebenso Plenum, Ausschusszuweisung und dann war am Montag der Gesundheitsausschuss und dort wurde mit den Stimmen der Regierung, also konservativer und grüner, inklusiver SPÖ.
Änderungen da rein geschrieben, die es in sich haben. Ähm da wurde nämlich äh bestimmt, dass die Daten aus dem elektronischen Impfpass, auch darüber habe ich in vergangenen Sendungen hier schon berichtet, alle Impfungen werden in Österreich voll erfasst.
Ähm und äh Daten aus dem Epidemiologischen Meldesystem, sprich da stehen alle,
Menschen drinnen, die äh positiv getestet wurden oder sonst irgendwie positiv mit Corona sind. Äh und eben diese Testdaten, die sie eh schon haben, verbunden,
und dann äh wird dem Gesundheitsminister auch die Möglichkeit gegeben, online oder offline Zertifikate für Immunitäten auszustellen.
Ähm und das Gesetz wurde irgendwie am Montag im Ausschuss sozusagen öffentlich das erste Mal. Das ist ein Initiativantrag, also das kam aus dem Parlament, nicht von den Ministerien.
Am Dienstag ist es uns aufgefallen und ich habe wie wild getrommelt äh und am Mittwoch wurde es schon im Plenum beschlossen. Ähm das heißt, das waren zwei Tage,
für ein Thema, was irgendwie äh ethisch, juristisch und technisch nicht komplexer sein könnte
ähm und äh es ist auch schon durch die zweite Karma des Parlaments durch, durch den Bundesrat und ähm wird's ja bald äh auch offiziell sein. Und äh da wurde jetzt wirklich eben äh ein ein extrem.
Thema durchgeboxt und ähm gleichzeitig hat sich Sebastian kurz hingestellt, unser Panzler und gesagt, ja, wir brauchen jetzt einen grünen Impfpass,
Wir brauchen eine genau, das ist wichtig, dass er grün sein muss. Wir kommen in eine.
Weil weil der Gelbe nicht der gelbe gefällt ihm nicht oder was?
Der gelbe Impffass der WHO ist das, was es schon gibt, du nimmst mir den äh Theaterdonner weg, ähm aber jetzt muss ich mich hinstellen und sagen, wir haben diesen gelben Pass, der ist doch viel besser, ja, aber der Kanzler, der vom Kanzler ist grün.
Kanzler will einen grünen.
Hühner ist besser als gelb. Wo ist das Problem? Ähm und und äh Sebastian Kurz ist da eben vorgeprescht, war, glaube ich, auch bei Maischberger und hat sich hingestellt, sodass wir das seine Idee, dass die EU jetzt so einen ähm Immunitätsausweis oder Impfpass
machen will und ähm.
Am Donnerstag oder Freitag war virtuelles Treffen der EU Staats und Regierungschefs und da ist auch Angela Merkel auf diese Forderung eingeschränkt.
Obwohl sie davor immer sehr dagegen war, gemeinsam mit Frankreich, Niederlanden und ähm Belgien. Aber ähm sie ist umgeschwenkt
und äh nun ist es so, ähm dass am Montag dieser Woche, am ersten März, ähm Ursula von der Leyen, EU-Gesetzgebung zum Thema elektronischem Impfpass angekündigt hat, für den siebzehnten März.
Und äh bevor wir da jetzt irgendwie in die in die rechtlichen Sachen reingehen, finde ich, sollten wir kurz pausieren und so diese Frage uns stellen, gesellschaftlich, was das.
Deutet. Ähm wir wissen, wenig Details und wir können dann noch über die technische Diskussion reingehen. Ich glaube, die ist sehr spannend.
Aber es ist so grundsätzlich gibt's da ja zwei Seiten. Man kann sagen ähm wir wollen solidarisch sein,
und ähm so wie die WHO das am Anfang genannt hat.
Und wir müssen hier irgendwie zusammenhalten und die die Impfung ist irgendwie der Weg in ein normales Leben, nicht so wie Sebastian Kurz sagt, der Impfpass ist das Ticket für ein normales Leben.
Und die zweite Seite der Debatte wäre natürlich.
Also äh ein Lockdown sind Grundrechtseingriffe des Staates, die sehr massiv sind und die sind für Menschen, von denen auch keine Fremdgefährdung mehr ausgeht. Das ist da, wo die Wissenschaft noch nicht ganz ist,
an vielen Stellen, ob man auch für andere nimmer ansteckend sein kann,
und wenn diese Fremdgefährdung auch nimmer gegeben wäre, dann ist es auch nicht mehr sachlich gerechtfertigt, dass der Staat mich einschränkt.
Ja, sehr schön zusammengefasst. Tim, was was denkst du.
Worüber.
Ja, zum Thema möchtest du einen Impfpass haben oder nicht?
Äh ich habe einen Impfpass.
Da stehen Dinge drin. Äh aber ich muss auch sagen, ich glaube, dass sich die gerade die Vorstellung eines Impfpasses ein wenig ändert.
Bisher war das eigentlich mehr so 'ne Merkhilfe für Leute um zu wissen was sie denn mal so geimpft worden sind und was man denn so demnächst mal wieder so impfen müsste,
seltensten Fällen musst du das konkret vorweisen. Wir hatten das Beispiel ja schon ein paar Mal so Gelbfieberimpfungen und so weiter,
äh in anderen Ländern. Da wird er halt auch akzeptiert und ist, glaube ich, auch auf absehbare Zeit erst mal so, dass was äh akzeptiert werden wird. So, selten hatten wir es mit dieser Situation zu tun,
dass eben eine Impfung, eine potenzielle Verbesserung.
Okay, mit der Ausnahmeeinreise in ferne Länder und so weiter. Also betraf immer nur sehr wenig Leute, die, glaube ich, am Ende dann auch äh das ausreichende Interesse hatten, so eine Impfung auch vorzunehmen,
nicht wieder die Zahlen sind und wie viele Leute sich da durchschleichen. Jetzt ist es sozusagen. Jetzt.
Betrifft es quasi jeden und es betrifft halt auch unmittelbar deine künftige.
Reisefreiheit, beziehungsweise überhaupt deine deine Freiheiten innerhalb der Gesellschaft, sofern denn Dinge sozusagen ohne Impfung unmöglich sein sollen.
Und äh jetzt kann man über zwei Sachen diskutieren. Das eine ist äh ist sowas an sich stadthaft. Da würde ich halt sagen, ja.
Und das andere ist, wie müsste denn das dann auch ausgeführt sein, damit es auch halbwegs zuverlässig und angemessen äh implementiert werden kann.
Glaube ich zwei Aspekte, die man hier auseinander halten muss. Das heißt, wenn deine Frage mehr in Richtung ging, im Paar ist, ja oder nein,
also in digitaler Form, ja, ich bin generell äh dafür, dass wir uns einfach besser aufstellen, weil ich meine, wir sehen ja auch, was diese ganze Abwesenheit von von Registern,
jetzt grade so macht, ja, wir sind einfach noch nicht mal in der Lage, eine Impfkampagne durchzuführen und insofern macht sicherlich auch eine neue Auflage eines Impfpasses äh erstmal Sinn, der Gedanke, der Grundgedanke.
Also die Frage ist also die ein,
Wenn es darum geht, eine Impfung nachzuweisen, kannst du eine Impfung nachweisen, dann hast du eine Impfung, was für eine? Die Idee, warum sie jetzt sagen, ah, der muss aber unbedingt digital sein, ist ja folgender. Oder die, die zu Grunde liegende Idee ist ja, dass sie eine schnelle,
durch Laien ermöglichen wollen. Das ist ja genau der Grund, warum sie sagen, ah okay, das QR-Code oder so, ne. Ähm jetzt ist das natürlich zum Glück sind die meisten, die so etwas bauen halt na ja.
Sagen wir mal noch wirklich auch auch wirklich nicht auf so dem höchsten technischen Niveau, so dass die halt meinen, geil, wir machen QR-Code auf eine URL.
Und dann steht unter der URL geimpft und ich meine, der Angriff ist halt,
total lächerlich, dass du halt einfach, ne, dann einfach auf eine andere Webseite leuchtest, wo wo steht hier Thomas Löhniger, es äh geimpft oder hat einen Test äh vor fünf Minuten gemacht oder was auch immer, ne?
Technisch saubere Lösung wäre natürlich so etwas mit digitalen Signaturen zu machen. Und da könnte man ähm da kann man.
Sehr schöne Dinge mit machen.
Da kann man aber auch sehr unschöne Dinge mitmachen. Das ähm bittere daran ist, also die, ich denke, die die entscheidende Eigenschaft ist hier, dass sie das machen wollen, zum sehr schnellen Check.
Alltagssituationen, ja? Dein, also dein Impfpass, ja, meiner ist ein bisschen abgegriffen, der ist auch gut voll, ne? Ah, ich hab den jetzt grade mal hier liegen, aber der, also, sagen wir mal, der hat
an dem ist erkennbar, dass ich jetzt nicht dass ich den nicht am laufenden Band vorzeigen muss, ne? Das ist jetzt nicht,
So und mit einem digitalen Impfpass schaffst du ja, wollen sie ja schaffen.
Dass du in Alltagssituationen möglichst an allen möglichen Stellen nach diesem Pass diskriminiert werden kannst.
So und da sage ich jetzt einfach, diskriminieren einfach nur im Sinne von einem Unterschied, eine unterschiedliche Behandlung, ne? Unabhängig davon, ob die jetzt positiv oder negativ ist. Und.
Kann mir durchaus vorstellen,
Also das wirst du nur brauchen, diese schnelle und viele und häufige Checks wirst du nur brauchen in einem Zeitraum, in dem noch nicht alle geimpft sind.
Irgendwann wird es wieder egal sein, ne? Also Stichwort Herdenimmunität wird's gerade hier noch eine Meldung gesehen in Israel feiern sie jetzt langsam wieder, weil sie weil die Normalität jetzt einfach einkehrt oder sie das hoffen oder so, ne. Und,
dieser Zeitraum, das habe ich, glaube ich, auch schon öfter hier in der Sendung gesagt, indem genug Leute geimpft sind,
und aber auch genug Leute noch nicht geimpft sind, dann kannst du nur betteln, dass der möglichst kurz ist und deswegen wäre das total gut,
Ja? Ich wär wirklich super, der Jens Spahner ist jetzt auch vorgeschlagen, dass wir vielleicht schneller impfen, ne? Danke Jens.
Guter Vorschlag, Jens, echt super, wenn wir Jens nicht hätten, ne? Der hat uns jetzt eine gute Idee gemacht. Wir impfen, wir impfen einfach schneller. Weißt du, was das für ein Vorteil hat, dann sind wir schneller fertig. So, ähm aber wenn dieser Zeitraum,
lang wird, dann hast du dann bricht dir wirklich, dann bricht dir die Zivilisation zusammen,
und wenn die nicht von alleine zusammen wenn die nicht von alleine einreißt, werde ich an der ersten Stelle sein, der die mit einreißen. Weil ich habe keine Lust, ja, ähm.
Also hier sind ja ein paar Kilometer vor meiner Wohnung entfernt,
sind die Impfzentren, wo die Leute gerade rum pimmeln, weil der keiner, weil weil die die Impflogistik nicht in die Kette kommt und da die die Terminvergabe nicht hinkriegen
Es ist ja nicht so, als gäb's keine Impfwilligen, aber die du da irgendwie nicht reinkommst.
Unter so einer Bedingung ja, dann irgendwie, wenn da demnächst einer steht und sagt, ich habe aber hier einen QR-Codescanner und ich scanne deinen ähm deinen Impfpass.
Völlig egal. Die die die des Wertwert wird die nichtgeimpfte Mehrheit nicht,
Punkt. Die schlagen von mir aus dem Typen mit dem QR-Code-Scanner die Nase ein, die kopieren sich die QR-Codes, das kannste sein lassen. Es wird ist gesellschaftlich,
nicht, es wird nicht funktionieren und wir können nur wirklich hoffen, dass dass wir nicht in eine solche Situation kommen.
Und wenn.
Dass sie nur unglaublich kurz ist, weißt du, dass du im Prinzip sagen kannst, alles klar in zwei Wochen ist mein Termin, dann habe ich auch so einen blöden äh so einen blöden QR-Code, ne. Aber solange du nicht in der gesamten Gesellschaft die,
mehr oder weniger die Möglichkeit hast, ne, ist das halt einfach nur eine schwerwiegende Diskriminierung.
Ja, ich stimme dir äh auch total zu, was die Einschätzungen betrifft, dieser dieser Übergangsphase und ich glaube auch nicht, dass wir ansatzweise irgendwas in so einer äh Alltagssituation funktionieren sehen werden. Allein schon deshalb, wenn man sich jetzt mal anschaut, wie derzeit
diese Impfbestätigung aussieht. Ich weiß nicht, ob du sowas schon mal gesehen hast, aber derzeit besteht so eine Impfbestätigung aus einem Dynamikszettel.
Soll ich sowas gesehen haben, Tim?
Bei jemanden, der das schon.
Ja, ich kenne halt, ich, ja, ich ich habe ja von einer Person, die ich kenne, die geimpft ist, schon erzählt. Die traut sich nicht mehr unter meine Augen. Und.
So, also ich habe äh.
Andere Leute rennen damit nicht rum und geben an, die ich mit denen nicht zu tun habe. Insofern, die habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Ja, also ist einfach ein Dinner sechs äh Zettel schwarz weiß mit ein paar Feldern drauf, so und da sind dann so ein paar ähm handgeschriebene Informationen.
Wann, was und dann gibt's noch diese diesen Impf,
Aufkleber, der im Wesentlichen steht da einfach nur drauf, der Name des Produkts, der geimpft wurde.
Den man auch in den in den Impf äh in den Impfpass reinklebt gerne, ne? Diese kleinen Aufkleber.
Also mit anderen Worten, null Fälschungssicherheit, null. Und äh in dem Moment, so Alltagssituationen ist das eine, ja, aber es gibt ja, sagen wir mal, auch so äh abseits des Alltags Situationen, zum Beispiel Reisen.
Ja, Tim, lass uns aber bitte mal ganz kurz bei den Alltagssituationen bleiben, weil um die geht es ja jetzt hier. So und der ähm.
Also klar, Fälschbarkeit ist eine so eine Sache, ne, aber,
in warum ich gegen diese Impfpass-Einführung für die Allgemeinheit bin unter der Bedingung, dass nicht alle diesen äh Impfpa äh diesen diese Impfung auch einfach zeitnah bekommen können? Ähm.
Hat eben deswegen auch bitte nicht diesen Impfpass, also sorry, ich muss ja mal sagen, also es können nicht alle die Impfung bekommen, es ist eben, ob du im Moment eine Impfung hast oder nicht,
hat darauf kannst du keinen Einfluss haben, ne? Es gibt einen gewissen Anteil Leute, die sich die jetzt erschleichen, ja? Und äh es gibt einen gewissen Anteil Leute, die ähm,
ja aus Solidarität ausharren und Lust haben ähm langsam Jens Spahn ähm auch mal mit ein paar Sachen zu impfen, ne? Und.
Es gibt aber ähm.
Also in die in dieser Situation jetzt ein Impf ein schnell Prüfsystem für für Geimpfte einzuführen wird ist ja nur der Weg dafür geimpften Privilegien zu geben. Und wenn du geimpften Privilegien gibst, dann.
Du an dem an dem Rest Zivilisation, den wir noch haben. Und genau deswegen darfst du das nicht machen.
Na ja, also äh ich würd's ja anders formulieren. Es ist ja nicht, dass man Privilegien bekommt, sondern man kriegt ja seine die Einschränkungen seiner Grundrechte zurück. Und das ist schon nochmal was anderes.
Genau das da waren wir vorher gerade, um es impfrillig nennen sollen oder oder nicht, aber ich glaube, auf einer politischen Ebene gibt's so so drei Gründe, wieso das meiner Meinung nach jetzt gerade kommt. Ähm.
Eine ist eine Debatte um einen Impfpass, ist eine willkommene Ablenkung von einer Debatte um die schläfende Impfung.
Und ich glaube, dieser Satz, der Impfpass ist das Ticket für ein normales Leben, den werden wir noch öfter hören. Und er ist einfach eine Lüge. Die Impfung ist das Ticket für ein normales Leben.
Der zweite Grund ist meiner Meinung nach um Menschen überhaupt zur Impfung zu bekommen. Ähm,
korrigiert mich über meines Wissens nach, gibt es noch keinen Impfstoff, der für Kinder zugelassen ist.
Wenn man die wegrechnen, dann brauchen wir für die Herdenimmunität von siebzig bis achtzig Prozent der Gesamtbevölkerung. Ähm wenn man auch nochmal jene weglassen, die aufgrund ihrer Gesundheit sich nicht impfen lassen
können, ähm wie Schwangere oder Menschen mit Immunschwäche circa neunzig Prozent der erwachsenen Bevölkerung, die freiwillig sich einer Impfung geben lassen.
Zumindest die Umfragen, die ich aus Österreich kenne, sind weit unter dieser Bereitschaft in der Bevölkerung ähm diese Maßnahme in ihrem eigenen Körper durchführen zu lassen.
Und
Ich will jetzt nicht über die ganze Impfpflicht, Debatte reingehen, das ist nochmal ein ganz anderes Fass, das man hier nicht aufmachen muss, aber weil das nicht kommen wird. Und ich glaube, die politischen Willensbegründungen, dass es das äh zumindest in deutschsprachigen Ländern nicht geben wird, glaube ich schon
dass man mit der Idee spielt über partielle Privilegien im Zugang zu.
Dienstleistungen, Kinos, Restaurants, Einreisebestimmungen anderer Länder, Anreize zu schaffen, dass mehr Leute diese Impfung machen.
Und zu dritt, der dritte Grund, meiner Meinung nach, sind Industrieinteressen, also es gibt in dieser Debatte von Anfang an ähm eher die Provider und andere Firmen, die damit ihren Lösungen,
sehr stark hausieren gehen und deren Standards teilweise auch schon in den Standardisierungen auf Seiten der Airlines und jetzt auch auf Seiten der Kommission, die ja schon Arbeitsgruppen zu diesem Thema hat,
ähm eine Rolle spielen.
Da kommen wir jetzt mal zu dem, zu dem, denke ich, relativ interessanten technischen Teil, weil auf der technischen Seite,
Also nur von der Betrachtung her finde ich das ja sicherlich auch hier im Podcast schon mal öfter gesagt. Ähm ist es eigentlich schön, solche Systeme zu haben, die mit
statt Identity rechnen.
Also du kannst mit schönen, also ist noch nicht mal besonders kompliziert, mit schön geschachtelten Keepern und Signaturen kannst du zum Beispiel so etwas machen wie ein Ausweis, ja?
Gespeichert ist, dass du zum Beispiel eine Fahrerlaubnis hast. Und wenn jetzt, wenn du nachweisen musst, dass du fahren darfst.
Dann könntest du quasi nur das Auslesen dieses Fahrfeldes ermöglichen.
Während du den, sage ich mal, deine persönlichen Daten, Adresse und so weiter nicht auslesbar machst
Einfach nur, weil du sagst, okay, ich gebe dir einfach nur dieses Bit und das hat oder dieses diesen Teil meiner Daten, da ist eine offizielle digitale Signatur drunter, dass die Eignerin dieser Karte ähm.
Einen Führerschein hat, ähm,
oder ne, geimpft ist oder was auch immer, ohne dass du quasi alle Daten, die auf der Karte gespeichert sind, auslesen lässt, zum Beispiel den Namen, ne? Also da kannst du sehr schöne Sachen mit machen.
Aber die Frage ist ähm ob sie das am Ende vorhaben.
Ich frage mich auch, ob ähm dass dass hier die Lösung ist, weil du hast ja im Grunde zwei Ebenen. Du hast die Ebene Gesundheitsdaten.
Und äh da gibt's so grob drei Ströme, aus denen die Daten kommen, an eine eine kürzliche Testung, Antigene oder PCR, eine durchgemachte Krankheit mit folgender Immunität und eine Impfung.
Und da ist schon die Frage, wie wertest du die in der jeweiligen Situation? Ich glaube, man kann eigentlich nur sagen, du bist immun bis zu einem gewissen Zeitpunkt, ja, nein. Und alles an weiterer Komplexität über.
Mutationen, die einen durch einen Immunescap auf einmal auch wieder gefährlich sein können für,
Menschen, die die Krankheit schon hatten und so weiter. Ich glaube nicht, dass das in so einem System drinnen sein sollte, auch aus Komplexitätsgründen, sondern du hast da einfach epidemiologische Rahmenbedingungen und du gibst diesen Zertifikaten einfach eine gewisse Gültigkeitsdauer
Aber der der zweite leer, die zweite Komponente in der Architektur ist eben die Identitätsprüfung.
Und äh da gibt es äh also mehr oder weniger die Frage, ist der Mensch, für den das Zertifikat ausgestellt wurde, auch wirklich die Person,
die gerade vor dir steht oder gehe ich übermorgen mit dem INF-Zertifikat von meiner Oma die heute geimpft werden sollte dann ins Kino,
Also äh das musst du natürlich auch sicherstellen und ähm deswegen auch ihr die Provider, also du hast extremes Interesse, Gesundheitsdaten zu öffnen für die Wirtschaft.
Stichwort elektronischer Gesundheitspfad und du hast bei dem eher die Thema seit vielen Jahren Bestrebungen, sowas in die Breite zu bringen,
die wir jetzt gerade in diesen Projekten potenziell drinnen haben,
ähm äh davon, dass das das kannst du mit Geld gar nicht bezahlen an Werbung, um das so in die Breite zu bringen.
Dein Punkt ist, die die Anbieter, die jetzt im Prinzip seit Jahren, das weiß ich ja auch durchaus, dass es solche Projekte gibt, sonst will ich's ja nicht erklären. Ähm.
Die denken jetzt im Prinzip sogar jetzt endlich unsere Stunde geschlagen, jetzt äh jetzt machen wir die äh die Anbieterin für den für den Immunitätsnachweis und dann haben wir mehr oder weniger,
Marktmarktführung.
Das ist die.
Haben diese Technologie eingeführt, ja.
Also ich glaube, das ist so ein Interesse, was hier mitspielt und die, die Leute sind auch mehr oder weniger offen mit dem Interessen, ja. Ähm
und äh deswegen ist äh das System in Österreich ist so gebaut, dass die Identitätsprüfung komplett offline basiert. Da muss halt, falls die Gastronomie öffnet, mit so einem System
deinen Ausweis kontrollieren. Und äh die Frage ist halt, wie funktioniert diese QR-Code-Prüfung und die ist im Moment in Österreich,
das haben wir aufgrund von Architekturfolien des Ministeriums komplett zentralisiert. Das heißt, das geht alles über eine URL, wo geprüft wird, ist dieses Zertifikat gültig.
Und äh das erlaubt natürlich einer zentralen Identität auch zu wissen,
Dass die Person mit diesen Zertifikat jetzt gerade in dieser Bar war, in kurzer Zeit mit den drei anderen Menschen ins Kino gegangen ist, sprich, du hast eine Stelle, die nichts anderes tun muss, als das Loggin aufzudrehen auf diesem Server,
und auf einmal hast du extrem feingranulare Daten über das gesamte gesellschaftliche Leben,
Deswegen muss es eine Designanforderung sein, dass diese Zertifikatsprüfung offline passieren kann und solche Systeme gibt es auch,
das E-VIsersystem von der internationalen Zivilflugallianz ist da ein gutes Beispiel, die komplett dezentral funktionieren und das kannst du auch in der App backen oder in in einer App auf einen betrieblichen Betriebssystem,
und äh über den Weg wär's auch machbar, äh sowas eben ohne zentrale Stelle äh zu designen.
Also du du dafür würde man ja dann halt äh CAs nehmen, ne? Also ich würde irgendwie sagen, alles klar. Eine Signatur kann vorgewiesen werden. Dafür hast du ja nun mal äh also dafür hast du ja halt ein Signatursystem, damit du nicht online prüfen musst.
Du könntest jetzt halt sagen, alles klar. Du machst eine App. In dieser App sind bestimmte
vorinstalliert, die sagen, alles klar, wenn mir etwas präsentiert wird, was damit signiert ist und eine immunität ausweist, dann akzept.
Was du eigentlich nicht kannst, ähm ist so ein System sinnvoll machen nur mit QR-Codes.
Weil was du eigentlich haben möchtest, um zu verhindern, dass Thomas mit dem QR-Code von seiner Oma ähm irgendwie ins Kino geht,
ist, du möchtest, du müsstest im Prinzip eine Kopier, einen Kopierschutz haben,
weil sie damit nicht zwei Personen mit dem gleichen QR-Code rummarschieren. Und der Kopierschutz, den machst du ähm also den,
kannst du nur sinnvoll machen, indem du das Ding entweder physisch schwer zu zu fälschen machst, siehe Geldscheine.
Dann kannst du zumindest sicherstellen, dass während du im Kino bist mit dem Impfausweis deiner Oma sie nicht ins Kino gehen kann, weil sie weil der nicht weil der physisch nicht kopierbar ist.
Oder technisch.
Dadurch, dass deine Karte selber auch wieder signiert und ein hat und dadurch ihre Einzigartigkeit beweist. Also, eine Smart-Card NFC, irgendetwas in der Richtung.
Oder zumindest irgendetwas, was einen Challenge Response Verfahren ermöglicht auf am Ende auf Basis eines Keepers, was du nicht klonen kannst. Und das wäre dann die, die,
die Variante und jetzt bin ich auf dünnem Eis, aber ich glaube sogar äh ich habe mich mal mit ein paar Leuten unterhalten, die mit dem.
Deutschen Personalausweis äh gearbeitet haben, dass so etwas da grundsätzlich auch drin Respekt wäre. Das wäre nicht ähm,
völlig außerhalb des Denkbaren, dass du halt zum Beispiel eine Situation hast, dass du weißt, okay
dieser, dieses ist signiert für ausweisend, dass diese Person geimpft wurde
Ist sicher in dieser Smartcard drin, das kann da keiner rauskratzen und klonen und dann könntest du ähm quasi.
Einen NFC-Scanner an an eine Smart-Karte jetzt beispielsweise dran halten. Wie gesagt, ich glaube sogar, es würde mit dem deutschen Personalausweis gehen und nur dieses Bit-Auslesen, alles klar, die Person ist geimpft und dann bräuchtest du nur noch ähm,
auf das Foto zu gucken, ob das ungefähr jetzt deiner Oma entspricht, wie du dich geschminkt hast. Aber das da da arbeitet natürlich jetzt gar keiner dran, ne?
Also ich glaube, dieses ganze Problem von wegen äh.
Doppelte Verwendung äh kannst du wirklich über Ausweise erschlagen, wenn du irgendwie die Information hast, für wen dieses Zertifikat ausgestellt wurde und du brauchst dann halt eine Ausweiskontrolle.
Ich glaube, ohne ohne dem ist es sowieso ähm nicht nicht denkbar, weil wir haben in,
Europa halt andere Ausgangsbedingungen als in Israel. Ähm dort gibt's ja so ein System. Und äh wir haben halt in Europa sehr hohe Datenschutzstandards und überhaupt keine Vereinheitlichung, was Identität betrifft,
Und äh ich habe äh zu dem Thema auch mit den Leuten gesprochen von, also jenen, die die Architektur für die
Stopp corona und Corona-Warnapp gemacht haben, die natürlich auch schon
seit vielen, vielen Monaten in diesem Thema drinnen sind, weil man sie initial auch gefragt hat. So, ihr habt einmal Privacy Bud Design durchgebracht. Wie ist es mit der nächsten großen Nuss?
Und deren einheilige Meinung ist es eigentlich, dass das absolut unrealistisch ist,
in dem Zeitframe, wo wir das überhaupt brauchen können. Also wenn's ums um die nächsten Monate geht.
Die die sprechen davon, ein einigermaßen taugliches System aufzubauen. Da sprechen wir von zwanzig dreiundzwanzig. Und äh ich ich glaube schon, dass.
Richtig. Das es ist übrigens auch das, was ich genau diesen Satz habe ich ähm wann war das denn am Sonntag oder so in in einem.
Ähm TV-Interview mit der WDR aktuelle Stunde gesagt hat, ich setze es vollkommen ausgeschlossen, dass ein solches Projekt
in in ähm in absehbarer Zeit ein solches IT-Sicherheitsgroßprojekt in absehbarer Zeit abgeschlossen wird, ausgerollt wird und funktioniert.
Ne? Das da stimme ich dir zu. Aber weißt du, was das Problem ist?
Das, daraus schließen die Regierungen ja dann, ah okay, da müssen wir ein einfacheres machen.
Machen wir halt was mit dem QR-Code, statt einem statt was was Sinnvolles, ne? Und wenn du's mit einem QR-Code machst, klar.
Ich meine, am Ende, ne, das Ding hast du in in kürzester Zeit geschrieben. Könntest du auch sogar eine App machen und sagen, alles klar, der der Aufruf ähm,
ist ja quasi durch TLS dann gesichert und damit weißt du, dass dir auf jeden Fall der zentrale Impfnachweis, halte es Server, antwortet und so. Also das das geht dann, wenn du,
Wenn du es nicht inordentlich machst, dann geht's auf einmal rucki zucki.
Ja und ich ich befürchte auch, dass es da einen enormen Druck auch aus der Bevölkerung geben wird, zu irgendeiner Lösung dafür zu haben
und eben äh wir wir reden nicht über die einfachen Fälle, wo's wo's auch gute Systeme gibt. Also ich glaube
ähm beim beim Grenzübertritt da gibt es den gelben Impfpass. Das ist ein Standard, der WHO. Der ist verfügbar, der ist billig, der funktioniert ohne Internet ohne Strom.
Der ist nicht fälschungssister, das ist mehr oder weniger nur gelbes Papier, da müsste man sich halt noch was überlegen. Die Forderung wäre einfach hier Hologrammsticker zu machen, wenn man's besonders sicher machen will, dann,
Hologrammsticker, wo der eigene Name eingraviert ist oder die Personummer, whatever, ähm die Technik gibt's,
und äh das ist wahrscheinlich auch nochmal billiger als das in der breiten Masse auszurollen für so ein System.
Obwohl Israel ähm die die QR-Code simple Variante genommen hat, gibt's dort auch schon Beschwerden, vor allem eben von Gastronomiestätten, die sagen, wir können an dem System nicht teilnehmen, weil es ist zu kompliziert und zu teuer.
Also ich glaube die diese Vorstellung, dass das einfach mit einer App geht, ist wirklich ein Trugschluss.
Kannst du dieses System, was in Israel zum Einsatz kommt, nochmal genauer erklären, wie das wie das äh.
Ich habe gesucht, aber ich habe da nicht wirklich was Brauchbares gefunden, das in einer Sprache war, die ich lesen konnte, wenn es da unter unseren Hörerinnen und Menschen gibt, die sich,
die die Hebräisch sprechen und die ähm da näher dran sind, würde mich das brennend interessieren. Äh ich habe nur äh eben von Berichterstattung gehört, dass es,
gab in der Ausrollung und eben auch jene, die mit diesem System kontrollieren sollten ihre Gäste äh darüber gemahnst haben, dass es so teuer und so kompliziert sei.
Also ich ich sehe da wirklich okay, dann lassen wir es mal kurz außen vor, wie gesagt, ich ich sehe den Zusammenbruch der Zivilisation
und ähm ich glaube, dass das, dass es nicht in eine richtige Richtung geht, so etwas zu machen, aber ähm,
Gut, wenn's Israel jetzt auch schon hat, dann werden sich werden sich die europäischen Leute das auch nicht nehmen lassen, ne?
Großbritannien äh für diese Debatte auch schon länger. Die sind ja auch im Impfung voran,
da hat es die Zivilgesellschaft aber bisher geschafft sowas äh hinten anzustallen. Ähm teilweise mit wirklich guten Argumenten. Wir verlinken da auch noch in den etwas vom Ada Loveless Institut, die ich prinzipiell auch sehr empfehlen kann für ihre Rep,
und Privacy International,
noch gibt es so etwas in UK nicht. Äh nachdem Ursula von der Leyen aber Gesetzgebung angekündigt hat und die Kommission hat das alleinige Recht, Gesetze vorzuschlagen, wenn die hier an Stein ins Rollen bringt,
ist er fast nicht mehr aufzuhalten. Also ich ich befürchte, dass wir hier viele Argumente brauchen, um das ähm noch von von der Schiene zu bringen,
Ich glaube wirklich, dass wir uns mehr Probleme schaffen mit so einem System als wir als wir lösen.
Und äh wir dürfen nicht vergessen äh SARS-CoV zwei wird sehr wahrscheinlich in dem.
Wir wissen nicht, wie das weitergehen wird, aber es ist absolut nicht gesagt, dass dieses Systeme temporär sind. Es kann auch sein, dass das ohne Sunset-Klaus dauerhaft sein wird.
Vor der letzten Pandemie vor hundert Jahren war das mit den Reisen und Reisepässen auch noch nicht so, wie wir's heute kennen. Also es kann schon sein, äh dass das hier zu einer Normalisierung führt von digitalen Zugangskontrollen, von,
ähm einer anderen Art vom Umgang mit Gesundheits- und Identitätsdaten.
Und äh deswegen ist es äh ich bin da selber auch noch im Denkprozess drinnen. Ich merke irgendwie so diese Entwicklung passiert gerade sehr schnell und,
mehr Leute zum Denken bringen dabei und äh meine Gedanken auch teilen, aber ich befürchte das mit ähm diesem Zeitplan eine saubere Lösung, wirklich ein Kraftakt sein wird.
Ähm im Moment ist so meine Hoffnung ebenso dieser IKO Standort für Evisas, wenn man's irgendwie in diese Richtung bringen könnte, mit Offline-Zertifikatsprüfung.
Dann dann wäre zumindest der Schaden einigermaßen minimiert. Und ähm.
Was man vielleicht auch noch sagen sollte, äh dass das äh die Aussagen von Ursula von der Leyen zumindest in die Richtung gehen, dass es dem Mitgliedsstaaten überlassen wird, ob und welche,
Erleichterungen. Es gibt, wenn man diesen Immunitätsausweis hat und ähm ist es aber auf jeden Fall aus der Perspektive des Binnenmarktes etwas, dass die EU jetzt schnell machen will,
weil natürlich diese Grenzschließungen auch ähm wie Deutschland sie gerade in Richtung Tirol und Tschechien hat, äh widerspricht natürlich dem Grundfreiheiten der EU,
und äh da will man natürlich jetzt auch irgendwie vielleicht auch mit aktionistischer Technik irgendwie dagegensteuern.
Und ähm der einzige Standard, den ich keiner auf EU-Ebene bisher einer, der nur für den medizinischen Bereich gedacht ist. Also wenn du eine eine Medizinanwendung machst
und äh dann Daten über Impfungen erhebst, dass man halt irgendwie standardisiert, welche Datenfelder das sein sollen. Ähm
und bisher ist die die technische Arbeit bisher nur in der Arbeitsgruppen.
Hm. Tim, wie sieht denn die zeitliche Planung im Moment aus? Wie viele Jahre dauert's denn noch, bis wir äh geimpft werden.
Na ja, ich meine, das hängt halt ein bisschen davon ab, wie gut es jetzt gelingt, die Impfkampagne anzudrehen, das jetzt im zweiten Quartal die Impfzahlen deutlich nach oben gehen werden, das das sehen wir ja im Prinzip jetzt schon, also es gibt
gab ja jetzt schon Steigerung.
Vorausgesetzt, man kriegt die Lieferung, die man eingekauft hat, vorausgesetzt das das Tempo hält so durch. Kann man irgendwie von September ausgehen, dass dann wirklich ähm.
Alles das geimpft wurde, was sich auch impfen lässt. Sagen wir's mal so. September.
September.
Aber das ist das ist jetzt eine Wischiwaschi äh Voraussage, weil das kann sich halt jederzeit äh ändern mit irgendeiner
Krise oder mit irgendeinem besonderen Impfskalierungserfolg und wie gut das mit den Hausärzten funktioniert. Ich denke, es hängt im Wesentlichen äh am Ende wirklich von der Bevölkerung ab
wie gut die mitmacht.
Erster oder zweiter, zweiter Impfung.
Zweite Impfung, also das ist.
Sagt die Info bis September. Okay.
Ja. Ist schon mein, aber.
Vielleicht du in deinem Alltag vielleicht, aber doch nicht ich.
Doch klar. Ich komme schon vorher dran. Ich komme vor den vor den Festivals und laufe mit meinem Impfpass schön am See und im September, wenn's kalt wird, dann darfst du hinterher reisen.
Tim, Tim marschiert mit Impf, was er so als Backstage.
Ja, es ist jetzt einfach nur so für Elder States Man und so.
Festival.
Spielen wir auch nur die Hits von früher. Ich würde mich eh nicht interessieren. Nur Death Punk, weißt du, alte Scheiße? Interessiert dich eh nie.
Also das.
Ja, es ist äh sehr noch zu überlegen, so bis September, solange die Impfung noch nicht frei verfügbar ist, ähm,
ob äh solche, wie nennen wir es mal, einfach Impfprivilegien, wenn man die wirklich macht,
Ich kenne jetzt noch keinen Staat, der das rechtlich normiert hätte. Ähm ob man da dann auch ähm die Impffreiung ändern müsste
weil ja eigentlich die Impfung dann nicht mehr nur etwas ist, das ähm gesundheitliche Effekte hat, sondern eben auch andere ähm im Moment ist halt äh
und ich kenne nur den den Impfflammen in Österreich detaillierter, aber das ist rein auf Gesundheit und Risiken in
dem Kontext ausgelegt und man könnte sich ja überlegen, ob man dann nicht auch die Supermarktverkäuferin oder den Kindergärtner vorreihen will
oder ob man alleinstehende Singlehaushalte alleine wohnendes Singles vor Pärchen-Wickies äh impft oder solche Sachen.
Also ähm wenn's wirklich ein Privileg ist, dann muss es auch wirklich ein solches verteilt werden und
Ich weiß nicht, bei uns ist jetzt dann bald die Regierung dran, also die Verwaltung und die Beamten haben sich da schon vorbereitet, obwohl es keine sachliche Begründung gibt dafür. Und äh das ist leider nicht nur ein Objektiv nach Alter von von hinten bis vorne durchgeimpft.
Du kommst auch irgendwann dran, keine Angst. Lass doch mal die älteren vor.
Ich wäre ja froh, wenn die Eltern vorgelassen würden, aber ich habe ich habe ja meinen Teil dazu schon gesagt, wie die Terminvergaben sind. Es ist äh ähm.
Ja fast so schlimm wie dieses Auflösungsvideo von.
Ines ist am Boden.
Der geht jetzt in die Wüste und sprengt sich.
Deswegen hat er das gemacht, weil der Orgel gesagt hat, ich kann diese Scheiße, wenn ich, ich kann mir das nicht mehr mit angucken.
Bitte ihre Jacke.
Der durfte nicht geimpft werden, weil er musste den Helm abnehmen. Also nee, ist nur mein Helm hier.
Musste sich ausweisen. Okay, haben wir das Thema Impfpass abschließend erörtert?
Ja, ja, ähm wir lassen das mal dabei und äh beobachten
Ähm ich habe noch irgendwie ein kurzes Update zum Digital Services Act und Digital Markets Act. Diese beiden Gesetze, die wir ja eh schon behandelt haben, ähm sind jetzt äh in Parlament und Rat und werden dort verhandelt.
Es gibt doch schon einen groben Zeitplan dafür, ähm nämlich äh im Mai will man schon,
die den Entwurf für die Reports haben, äh also die einzelnen Ausschüsse machen ja immer ihre Reports äh auf Basis derer dann eben Änderungsanträge.
Ähm noch möglich sind, aber das ist sozusagen die, die Stellungnahme der einzelnen Fachausschüsse zu den zwei Gesetzen. Ähm am ersten,
Juli äh ist die Deadline dafür Änderungsanträge einzureichen für die Abgeordneten, solche Änderungsanträge müssen,
entweder von der Fraktion oder von, ich glaube, das sind ungefähr achtundzwanzig Abgeordneten unterschrieben werden, dann können sie im Plenum abgestimmt werden,
Und äh also zuerst mal sind wir bei den Komitis. Das Lied Comity ist Imcho, also der Konsumentenschutz und Binnenmarktausschuss,
der sollte im November fertig sein und der ambitionierte Zeitplan, der jetzt gerade eben ausgegeben wurde, wäre, dass man im Dezember,
Jahres schon wirklich im Plenum über das Gesetz abstimmt
Ähm ich halte das äh für sehr ambitioniert. Also ich würde wirklich mich wundern, wenn wir es gerade in der Pandemie schaffen, diesen Zeitplan einzuhalten. Diese zwei Gesetze
in diesem Jahr schon durchzubringen. Der Grund, wieso man so darauf pocht ist, dass Frankreich in seiner
Ratspräsidentschaft in der ersten Jahreshälfte zwanzig zweiundzwanzig das Gesetz gerne fertig machen würde.
Und äh die Franzosen sind im Netz politischen Themen ja nicht unbedingt Freunde der Freiheit. Wenn man sich ein Upload-Filter und Überwachung erinnert, diese Themen sind da nur beispielhaft,
und äh ja, deswegen, das ist zumindest mal jetzt so der Zeitplan von den ambitionierten,
ähm Menschen, ich glaube aber, dass das Ganze so komplex ist, dass wir äh durchaus auch noch mehr Debatte brauchen dafür,
hat bisher auch bei der Datenschutzgrundverordnung meinte man, das in einem Jahr zu schaffen und es hat dann viel länger gedauert.
Ähm es gibt auf jeden Fall auch noch die Möglichkeit, sich selber ähm einzubringen in diesen Prozess,
die EU-Kommission hat da so ein Tool, das heißt,
und da wird der Gesetzestext äh wir von der Kommission vorgeschlagen wurde, auch gerade konsultiert und man kann dort auch noch sein eine Stellungnahme abgeben,
ähm die nicht lang sein muss und für den DSA, also die Haftungsregeln hat man bis zum dreißigsten März Zeit und zu dem DMA die Regeln für die Großen,
Internetplattform noch bis zum siebzehnten April und wir verlinken natürlich die die Möglichkeiten, sich da einzubringen, wenn jemand wirklich in den Text einsteigen will.
Mhm. Wie läuft's da insgesamt? Also noch kann man nicht genau sehen, ob's ob's ob's gut bleibt oder so, ne? Das ist jetzt, das wird dann danach passieren, ne, wenn die ganzen Einreichungen waren.
Ähm man kann schon ein bissel was absehen von den von den ähm Positionierungen, die die Parteien einnehmen. Ähm,
Da habe ich jetzt aber auch nur die großen menäa angeschaut und die konservativen Wind sind wie zu erwarten äh äh Worst Case. Ähm,
da äh ist Axel Voss mit dabei, da muss man gar nicht diskutieren, das ist nicht mehr zu retten,
Ähm und äh bei den Sozialdemokraten schaut's aber gut aus. Also die scheinen zumindest das Thema ähm Werbewirtschaft und Online-Tracking für sich entdeckt zu haben. Und das ist ja oft so die Wurzel des Problems. Die Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie
viel mehr als jetzt die Entscheidung, wie man mit einzelnen Inhalten umgehen muss,
Und äh die Sozialdemokraten haben äh den Berichterstatter für den DSA. Da ist eine dänische Sozialdemokratin ähm sozusagen im Fahrersitz und äh bestimmt über den Prozess im Parlament und auch in den Verhandlungen im Trilog.
Also ähm das ist durchaus eine gewichtige Stimme. Ähm,
Übrigens, an der Stelle sollten wir uns kurz freuen äh äh Viktor Orbans Partei, die vieles ist ja aus der Europäischen Volkspartei ausgetreten heute. Was ein sehr schönes Signal ist, weil jetzt ist das auch endlich mal abgesplittert und die,
Parteis auf EU-Ebene dadurch natürlich auch massiv geschwächt worden, weil Orban mit seinen Abgeordneten doch ein signifikanten Teil der Fraktionsgröße gestellt hat.
Aha, ich hab das war wie gesagt, ich habe ein bisschen wenig Nachrichten konsumiert in letzter Zeit und äh war jetzt wusste noch nicht genau, wie ich das bewerten soll. Also ist eine ist eine gute Nachricht.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall eine gute Nachricht.
Bisschen peinlich für die EVP, dass sie es nicht selber geschafft haben, die rauszuschmeißen.
Absolut. Das war Manfred Weber, der hat das damals versemmelt.
Aber die haben, es hat sich doch noch irgendeiner nicht entblödet zu sagen, das wäre jetzt schade.
Ja, macht, aber das war ein ehrlicher Machtpolitiker, der eine Träne geweint hat. Ist doch schön.
Ja, also DSA und es ist weiterhin super spannend und wer da Lust drauf hat, kann gerne ähm ein Auge drauf werfen, es wird auch viel berichtet auf Netzpolitik org, bei edri und bei uns und
Ähm das läuft und äh ich hatte dann noch ein Thema, von dem ich glaube, es ist noch gar nicht hier behandelt worden,
der.
Die Abkürzung kannte ich noch nicht.
Haben wir noch nicht besprochen, Thomas.
Genau, der DGA. Äh.
Dicker.
Diggah, äh.
Der Täter Governance Act ist ein weiteres Gesetz der Europäischen Union, das vorgestellt wurde und jetzt gerade verhandelt wird
Und da geht's mehr oder weniger um die kommerzielle Weiternutzung von Daten des öffentlichen Sektors. Ähm und damit versucht man irgendwie so.
Jene Daten zum Teilen und zum Weitergeben zu bringen, die normalerweise aufgrund des Datenschutzes geistiger Eigentumsrechte oder von Geschäftsgeheimnissen äh vor dem zukünftig Dritte geschützt sind.
Ihr merkt, das ist so irgendwie zwei von drei. Äh wäre der Datenschutz dann nicht auch dabei, könnte man fast sagen, dass ist ein gutes Gesetz.
Die Wikipedia freut sich auch so prinzipiell wegen den Einschränkungen von zum Beispiel Datenbankrechten da durch dieses Gesetz es werden hier nämlich auch Anmelderegeln geschaffen,
ähm für Institutionen, die eben Daten weiterverwenden wollen oder und da ist die Wikipedia sicherlich eine davon.
Aber diese Regeln sind sehr breit gehalten für diese sogenannten Treuhänder oder,
Problem ist hier, dass
durchaus ähm große Tech-Konzerne wie Facebook oder vielleicht sogar wie Palatier ähm äh durchaus auch in diese Kategorie reinfallen könnten und äh die brauchen sicherlich keinen Datenaltruismus.
Dieses Gesetz ist eine Weiterentwicklung der sogenannten PSI-Richtlinie, also
und äh das ist so irgendwie einer der Bausteine äh in, im Open Data Konstrukt der Europäischen Union. Also an sich was Gutes, äh das Hauptproblem ist, dass sie da irgendwie
personenbezogenen Daten im Scope drinnen haben, die müssen da ganz einfach raus. Also das äh widerspricht auch der Datenschutzgrundverordnung,
Und äh sollte deswegen einfach rausgestrichen werden,
weil du willst da nicht wirklich zwei gleichwertige Regelsets haben und wenn du hier irgendwie im Bereich von Daten-Altros.
Gelten dann Datenschutzgrundverordnungsregeln für Förderprocessing oder Regeln der ePrivacy nicht.
Das schafft einfach Schlupflöcher und Hintertüren, die gefährlich sind
und äh deswegen ist es ein Gesetz, was so mix back ist. Es gibt gute Sachen da drinnen und es gibt Gefahren und deswegen wollte ich's einfach hier mal erwähnt haben, wir verlinken auch noch den Gesetzestext und
ähm eine Einreichung von der Arbeiterkammer in Österreich, die alle irgendwie auch gut sind, um sich mal diesem Thema zu nähern, falls es äh Leute gibt, die sich mit Open Data mehr beschäftigen wollen. Ähm ist das vielleicht ganz spannend.
Ist bisschen auch so lieb, Datenaltroismus, ne? Hast du dir das Wort jetzt ausgedacht oder äh.
Das steht da drinnen.
Ich musste grade lachen und ich habe dich bewundert für deinen Humor.
Steht im Gesetz, kann kein Witz.
Dann.
Ich kann mich gerade, ist das jetzt eigentlich was Gutes oder ist das irgendwie das Gegenteil von Datenschutz?
Ja, das ist.
Teilst deine Daten mit anderen. Du bist doch so klug, lass es die anderen wissen.
Daten Altruismus. Super. Was kommt als nächstes, ey?
Nee, was, also, also Daten Altro ist.
Aber das ist doch dann also Datenalthrourismus macht man dann geht man doch dann eher bei irgendwo wo alle was davon haben, oder? Jetzt irgendwie in der medizinischen.
Forschung oder so könnte man ja vielleicht von einem solchen Begriff reden oder oder weil du hast das ja in einem Satz mit Palandtier genannt. Also ich meinte,
bevor ich jetzt gegenüber althruistisch werde, äh muss noch ein bisschen was passieren.
Also äh es ist halt eben genau an der Stelle ist das Gesetz nicht konkret genug. Es ist schon natürlich teilweise die Rede von wohliger Allgemeinheit. Aber ähm,
Man müsste das halt so scharf äh formulieren, dass sowas wie Wikipedia klar drinnen ist oder ich weiß nicht, äh frag den Staat, wenn das dort äh relevant sein könnte,
aber eben nicht Adresshändler, eben nicht Überwachungskonzerne. Und äh ja, diese Hausaufgaben hat die Kommission hier noch nicht gemacht und deswegen,
das das Parlament sehr wahrscheinlich tun.
Ja, in Brüssel beginnt's jetzt auch wieder normal zu arbeiten. Also die haben dieses Jahr sind auch noch alle irgendwer Homeoffice. Das Parlament wird ist ist weiter geschlossen. Die,
Die Leute gehen da nur rein, wenn sie vor die Kamera treten, im Plenum und sonst ist eigentlich, glaube ich, fast alles virtuell, soweit soweit ich das gehört habe vom Kollegen, die dort sind. Ich war dann lange nicht mehr in Brüssel,
die Arbeit geht weiter.
Okay, Tim, so, also du bist, Tim ist bis September zweite Mal geimpft, dann kannst du ja schon mal auch ein bisschen ähm.
Du bist bis September geimpft.
Achso, du bist früher geimpft oder was?
Ja klar, ich habe ja gesagt, ich bin noch vor der Festivalsaison durchgeimpft und.
Termin oder was?
Psst.
Wie kannst du, das ist so ein so ein treu doofer.
Nee, ich bin nicht geimpft, ich habe nur so einen QR-Code zugeschickt bekommen. Damit komme ich dann natürlich überall rein.
Neid.
Ernste, der glaubt ernsthaft, dass innere mit mit Jens Spahn als Gesundheitsminister eher bis September seine zweite Impfung hat.
Ich meine mal ehrlich, ne, mit so einem Konzept, wenn wenn die Leute sagen, ja, äh du brauchst nur einen QR-Code und dann dann scannen die Leute das mit dem Handy ab und dann steht da, ja oder nein.
Machen die Leute? Du setzt dir einfach deine eigene Webseite auf, machst dir einen QR-Code mit der URL drauf. So und dann steht da äh ja der Tim, der der nicht nur der ist nicht nur geimpft, der hat auch einfach Backstage-Ausweis,
Full Catering. Das steht doch alles in diesem QR-Code drin. Staatlich beglaubigt.
Ja, vielleicht sollten wir sie ihm doch nicht sagen, wie viele anfällig das System ist.
Inklusive inklusive Darkroom und das volle Programm, ne?
Auf welche Festivals gehst du diesen Sommer?
Alle. Alle beide. Ciao. Schauen wir mal, wie's läuft.
Könnte noch ganz holprig äh werden, aber wir dürfen natürlich nicht unseren Optimismus verlieren, oder?
Realismus.
Wir sprengen ihn in der Wüste.
Schluss jetzt hier.
Schön war's.
Schluss. Also einer Thomas jederzeit gerne. Herzlich willkommen. Du kannst äh noch andere Themen. Die Frage ist halt.
Also wir müssen auf jeden Fall wenigstens den Pakt machen, dass der Erste von uns, der einen Impfausweis bekommt, den dann auch den anderen beiden zugänglich macht.
Weil sonst können wir bei Tim weiß ich nicht. Der Tim ist so einer, der macht das dann nicht. Weißt du? Der sagt so, nee, nee, Linus, du musst noch geben.
Impf aus, weil ich gehe davon aus, dass wenn du eine Impfdosis hast, dass dass du die dann teilst.
Mal Hälfte ab hier.
Ich sehe uns schon Nadelteilen.
Dann impft aber was noch.
Wir sind Blitzbrüder, wir müssen immer gemeinsam geimpft werden.
Holen uns noch so eine Hepatitis C mit dran, so corona geimpft, ja klar, schwarz irgendwie im Hintergrund.
Tja. Geimpft gegen Corona, aber dann leider eine Blutvergiftung gestorben. Toll! Toll!
Anyway. Lasst euch impfen, wenn ihr die Gelegenheit habt und ähm ansonsten müsst ihr halt weiter durchbuchen als Politiker. Weil wir sonst nichts zu tun habt.
Ja
Danke fürs Durchhalten.
Ja, danke fürs Kommen, Thomas, danke fürs Zuhören, Leute und äh macht es auch weiterhin so und wir wünschen euch noch eine angenehme.
Oder was auch immer gerade vor oder hinter euch liegt. Und dann hören wir uns bald wieder. Bis bald.
Ciao, ciao.